[Music]
almost 30 years ago to the day the
european union was born here in the
dutch city of maastricht just a stone's
throw from where the maastricht treaty
was signed citizens taking part in the
conference on the future of europe met
to set out their recommendations to
reform the eu
over the weekend some 200 participants
of the fourth european citizens panel
voted on ideas on the eu's place in the
world in terms of trade solidarity and
migration recommendations covered topics
like making the eu more self-reliant in
terms of imports and resources
citizens also put forward ideas for
uniform eu rules on the treatment of
refugees and how to address the causes
of migration
the same human rights should be
protected around
the whole of the eu this is
to prevent the pushbacks and the the
violence around the the borders around
the migrant camps
the promotion of eu values like
democracy and citizen participation was
also discussed
we're trying to focus mostly on that on
projecting this value of democracy both
inward and possibly inspiring other
countries to follow in our footsteps
participants recommended ways to ensure
imports are ethically and sustainably
produced protecting both human rights
and the environment the 20 citizens
representing this panel will champion
its 40 recommendations in march at the
conference plenary of the european
parliament in strasbourg
so
and their peers will feed into a final
report which eu institutions have to
follow up on
[Music]
you